welcome back super zoo is in town right
now over at mandalay bay and one thing
that will definitely be on display is
pet treats patrondologist charlotte reed
joins us right now with a look at
something yummy for our furry friends
good morning charlotte always good to
see you
good to see you too good morning to
everyone at your station
so why do we like to spoil our pets with
treats especially our dogs
well we love our dogs so much we want to
give them treats which are great and
also we love food and dogs are food
motivated so why not give them a little
tasty snack
so what are what are dog owners looking
for in treats are we looking for healthy
stuff or do we feel like it's just it's
kind of cheating the way we like to
cheat with treats
what's the latest
well really they're looking for all
natural treats treats that are made and
sourced in the united states and treats
that are healthy they want to be able to
recognize the ingredients whether it's
chicken lamb salmon and they also want
treats with a purpose and that match
they're not their lifestyle
affordability is also a factor
so can we get good healthy treats that
are also affordable like i'm always
looking for ones that'll help clean
nala's teeth
when i want to spoil her a little bit i
just want to trick her into saying
here's a treat but it's actually going
to do something good for your body
great well absolutely you can so let me
give you a rundown of some of the trends
that we're seeing right now so right now
we're seeing me too treats okay so
remember vegetable booty so we've got
puffsters it's kind of a puffy treat
we've got deli licious for all those
people who like jewish deli i can tell
you right now this week i'm going to be
at weiss is having pastrami and corned
beef then we've got our doesn't it sound
great natural value
once again all made in the u.s safe as
you can see from the labels it's a
chicken recipe you've got more packed in
the bag which is great for
nayla with her uh teeth dental problems
you got tooth sticks and what i like
about two sticks is the shape is great
because it massages the gums and
eliminates plaque and tartar for
lifestyle products for those who like to
train foundations what i love about this
this is what i was talking about
lifestyle it's got a carabiner right
here they're really small you know
studies have shown that high value
treats and training helps dirt helps
dogs learn quicker also jerky treats are
the number one treat in the united
states and you've got these loving pets
bone shaped jerky treats what i like
about them is they're really really soft
so
dogs of all ages can enjoy them they've
got peanut butter and bacon flavored
also you also see jerky treats for
multi-purpose treats so active pets
which is another loving pet uh brand of
treats they actually are fortified with
multivitamins some of our immune support
some are for jet uh joint health but one
of the new products that came out that i
really like are these yummy bones that i
i'm showing you right here there's like
a center and what i love about these is
they're substitute treats so rawhide
isn't necessarily so great for dogs
teeth and it can cause all types of
intestinal problems so this is a nice
big chew that dogs can have it has a
yummy center whether it's bacon and
cheese and peanut butter so it's nice
that you can see the dog's really
interested in the treat so whether they
have them but here's what i love about
it it's for uh pet owners who are on the
go let's say you're going for a summer
vacation what i love is that it's
individually wrapped oh that's great
so this is really nice and you know what
i'm thinking i'm thinking this treat has
a future for halloween so if dogs come
to your house you can pass out good idea
bones and they'll get single servings
and pet parents just like regular
parents notice i say pep versus
parents like red so pet parents don't
have to worry about safe healthy treats
one of the nice things that all of these
treats are by loving pet products uh and
there it's a family owned small business
company and they really make healthy
affordable and treats for every single
lifestyle and every single dog so that's
the best thing sounds great charlotte
all good ideas and it's a treat for our
pocketbook as well great to see you
super good ideas have a great time at
super zoo
thank you